despite doing well with critics and
having Valli guns started with its first
season Swamp Thing has gotten the axe at
DC Universe from debunked rumours to
behind-the-scenes drama here's a look at
everything that led to this comics
adaptations quick cancellation the first
sign that the series was tumbling it
came even before the first episode aired
on DC Universe in late May 2019 in
mid-april it was reported production on
Swamp Thing was being shut down early
and that the show's first season
originally planned for 13 episodes was
being whittled down to 10 there was no
word on exactly why some things first
season was cut short but the news
certainly didn't boost fun confidence
neither that are now deleted Instagram
posts from one of the series cast
members Virginia Madsen who played the
troubled Maria Sunderland and Swamp
Thing wrote on her Instagram page I'm
beyond sad what a terrible decision
we have been cut to the core by those
who have never set foot into the swamp
even executive producer James Wan
admitted to being baffled by the
decision to sing Swamp Thing although he
still encourages fans to check out the
first season in an Instagram post at one
Rhodes don't really know or understand
the why Swamp Thing was cancelled but I
can tell you this all the cast and crew
and producing writing team or their
hearts into this really proud of
everyone's hard work go watch episode 2
and immortalize these 10 episodes
swampy deserves they're one of the
earliest and the most widespread
speculations about the show's sudden
cancellation was made by movie's
songwriter John Golson in a series of
now deleted tweets the story which has
since been debunked is that Swamp Thing
was cut short because of an accounting
error blamed on the state of North
Carolina where the series was filming
it's probably just some accounting error
it is not an accounting error well it
could be it is not an accounting error
the story went that Swamp things budget
was 80 million dollars and the North
Carolina through a program and to
encourage filmmaking in the States had
promised to cover 40 million dollars of
the production costs through state
grants then our calling to Golson story
someone in the North Carolina government
messed up and Swamp things production
was only granted twelve million dollars
of the promise forty million dollars so
short twenty eight million dollars a
Swamp Thing production closed up shop
okay my bad shut it down
but shortly after golson's story began
to circulate Screen Rant reported that
his accounting error theory simply
wasn't true Swamp Thing was granted 12
million dollars for its first season's
production they were also allowed a
separate grant of 4.9 million dollars
for the pilots episode there was never a
discussion of north carolina picking up
half the bill for Swamp Thing according
to Sir Matt the cancellation of Swamp
Thing it doesn't only impact that series
but could threaten every other DC
Universe show in June 2018 AT&T
completed its acquisition of Time Warner
of which the DC Universe streaming
service as a part went deadline reported
Swamp things cancellation the outlet
pointed out that quote DC Universe is
being reevaluated following the
completion of AT&T acquisition the
implication seems to be that if one a
media is going to have its own streaming
service a separate DC Universe streaming
platform what might be considered
redundant if that's the case then
producing new original series in the
interim could be considered a waste
commenting on the cancellation of
swampthing on the hora website bloody
disgusting right sir Brad Miska
speculated a Swamp Thing had become
quote the first of probably many
scapegoats the problem miss co-wrote is
that DC Universe was experiencing
problems and something had to give
comparing it to AMC's handling of the
horror streaming service shudder he
criticized DC Universe are giving up too
soon Miska certainly could be rights
perhaps suffering in Marvel's shadow on
the big screen has made Time Warner
executives more skittish in the face of
anything less than complete and
undeniable success with some time having
passed since from things cancellation it
now seems like the series premature
ending could be chalked up for the
oldest showbiz roadblock of all they've
got some real creative differences the
playlist reported that the call to
shorten Swamp Thing was a creative
decision and not part of a reevaluation
of DC universes performance which they
said was quotes outpacing expectations /
film likewise reported the season
truncation was due to creative
differences one of the few sites
Starfire any specifics in their update
was bloody disgusting who claimed their
source told them the creative
differences in questions were about the
nature of the series according to the
site's some people behind the scenes
wanted Swamp Thing to be a horror series
it was very important for all of us it
beeps to be granted more in the horror
genre while others wanted a weekly
procedural we're not sure how anyone
pictures a swamp monster might be able
to just crime scenes for fingerprints
but okay check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you